avoir des unités robotisée à l'horizon
2040 en s'appuyant sur des systèmes déjà
utilisé ou en cours de développement
l'objectif du projet vulcain de l'armée
de terre présenté lors de la journée
robotique à satory des systèmes
automatisés au coeur de la collaboration
entre l'armée de terre et les
industriels de la défense
si on veut vraiment progressé faire
progresser la france côté industriel
côté business et nos armées je parle
pour l'armée de terre
il est important qu on coopère mais tout
en synergie pour demain à voir la
supériorité opérationnelle sur nos
éventuels et l'armée terre elle n'a pas
la capacité de production des matériels
et on n'a pas forcément non plus toute
la matière grise pour réfléchir c'est
quoi le c'est quoi la conflictuelle
enfin les équipements qu'il nous faut
pour l'accomplir tu alité des années
voilà donc il faut des bureaux d'études
des bureaux d'études ils sont dans les
chais des industriels pour cette journée
17 entreprises ont pu présenter leurs
technologies robotiques et systèmes
autonomes
c'est le cas de shark robotics cette pme
basée à la rochelle développe ses deux
robots avec des fonctions différentes se
développe actuellement sur le secteur
défense et sécurité également avec le
robot barracuda que vous pouvez voir ici
qui est une mule multi missions pour le
support des forces armées en opex autres
solutions présentées lors de cet
événement avec ce drone enseignement
reconnaissance et identification les
usages de ce système relié à une station
au sol une technologie développée par
thales sur le site et l'on peut donc ce
système de drones
c'est un système avec une station sol
liaison de données et 3 vecteur aérien
comme celui ci qui permettent d'observer
de renseigner de désigner tout au long
des opérations des forces armées de
terre sur le drone vous pouvez retrouver
un des éléments les plus importants qui
la boule optronique qui est une boule
gyrostabilisée avec une voix à jour les
pratiques voix jours aux définitions une
caméra infrarouge pour voir de nuit et
aussi à
un dessinateur laser qui permet de
désigner pour expérimenter les systèmes
une section robotique sera créé à l'été
2000 21 au centre d'entraînement aux
actions en zone urbaine à sissonne dans
le département de l'aisne